okay here we go  Wow Let's Take This  yes this is not here my Maxim well  Bishop C5 would be a normal lion yeah  okay  you just take a pawn  isn't it too  pawns yeah  [Music]  so that didn't work out well no no  Bishop G4 no I don't know  and it's basically they moved to any  Square Bishop is on such a Magnus move  it's played  well it doesn't matter it's uh they can  create four but okay now at least two I  Can Dream yeah Queen E2 F5 adjust for  it's game over  I can tell you what's the score now  almost plus six already oh yeah that's  okay now it doesn't really matter no no  yeah  no it's not on Sunday come on  MC  use  it's a big match  little Bishop C7 was a nice trick it  just uh right back you think Magnus had  it under control probably he did yeah  yeah I think so